would you I mean obviously um
you saw kind of like both extremes of
playing in LA from the Clippers
seeing how it was
even though you guys were in the same
building did you feel that like just the
different like
organizationally did you feel the
difference in terms of like management
culture all that [ __ ] well everything is
different yeah you know what I mean
expectancy the expectations are crazy
yeah like the Clippers
um
to this day
you know
if
they had a better season than Lakers
than you know then they had a great
season yeah and also no one gives them
filming the lake is trying to be the
best team in the NBA yeah so I think
that's the difference
in the town too
yeah
[Music]
there ain't no difference oh no no if
you live here you know nobody [ __ ] with
the Clippers no they do but not many
people they do yeah there's a there's a
few a couple shout out to my man clever
Darrow Clipper Daryl has something I
mean I'm gonna be I'm gonna keep it real
with you he's lost bets to me
you know shout out to my man Kadeem
Hardison
Malcolm in the Middle
like they were there when
we was expected to lose uh what's the
old old comedian dude's name uh
that's always at the Clipper games the
old white dude he had a sitcom
[ __ ]
you know what I'm talking about bro oh
no my rookie year bro we lost 20 games
in a row about 20.
so I mean who's average again blown out
you lost 20 in a row by 20. that's a
total fat is that a fat is that like a a
record I don't know probably got to be
close to it oh my God now was that the
year before was Michael the artery with
y'all yeah wow that was his second year
yeah my rookie year was your second year
damn
great that's terrible
was Alvin Gentry the coach and one of
our coaches oh man that's that's
like some Detroit Lions [ __ ] I mean the
Clippers low here like uh I feel like
before Chris Paul went to the Clippers
I looked at the Clippers as like the
worst organization in all sports you
know until they got Obama
right because the owner a team is going
to be a reflection of the owner I mean
even before he sold I mean when there
was Blake Griffin in CP it was like okay
cool they at least they're they're good
no yeah they were turning around because
the the product they had Talent yeah
yeah and there's some energy yeah Chris
Paul was a veteran yeah even though he
had you know young Blake Griffin that's
what I'm saying if
if my team just had like a different
presence just a presence not even the
output on the court right you know what
I'm saying just to tame us off the court
help us with our practice habits and
[ __ ] like that that team would have been
made noise in the playoffs